So, right now, I'm putting on my headset...
...and I could see a kind of a jet plane in front of me.
I'm about to put on my headphones.
Looks like we're in some sort of futuristic landing pad to take off on this plane.
I'm gonna put on my headphones, I'm gonna turn around and turn on the game.
So, I have these controllers, whoops.
So, these are my controllers.
They're like little shooters.
We're gonna turn around.
Ready to rock.
There we go.
Okay, I'm kind of in outer space now.
I'm trying to shoot aliens.
Oh, I'm not a very good shot.
Okay, I could use some practice here.
I feel like this is like, a very futuristic Duck Hunt from the old days of Nintendo.
And it's all very immersive.
So, when I walk too far here, I can see the wall.
It says I shouldn't touch that, whoa!
Hey guys, the shield is awesome.
Now I have two shields.
That's amazing.